hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
Koch's postulates Koch's postulates are
a set of four criteria that were
established by a guy named Robert Koch
there's a little bit of confusion
regarding how his last name is
pronounced some people say cook some
people say Koch some people say Koch so
depending on your teacher you might hear
it pronounced differently but I'm going
to call it cooks postulates these are a
set of four criteria that establish a
causal relationship between two things
specifically between a pathogen and the
disease
so basically these four criteria help
determine that a specific bacterium
for example bacillus anthracis causes a
specific disease for example anthrax
let's look at these four criteria first
you have to find the candidate bacterium
in every case of the disease
so if we go with our example of anthrax
every single time you have someone with
anthrax you have to find the specific
bacterium that you think causes that
disease in every case of that disease
next you have to be able to isolate the
bacterium or the pathogen from the host
and specifically you have to be able to
isolate that bacterium and grow it in
pure culture
that means you have to isolate the
bacteria from the host and grow it on
auger media or in liquid media in a
laboratory where you know that you are
growing just that one species of
bacteria and no other contaminating
species then you have to show that the
cultured bacteria from step 2
you have to show that that cultured
bacteria causes the same disease in a
healthy host
this would mean taking this bacterium
that you're growing in pure culture and
then injecting it into a healthy subject
usually an animal model like a mass to
see that it causes the same disease in
that healthy subject once you've
infected it with this bacterium and then
finally the fourth criterion is that you
have to isolate that same bacterium from
the experimental subject so once you
take in the bacterium growing in pure
culture infected a healthy subject with
it to show that it causes the same
disease
you then have to be able to re isolate
that same bacterium from the
experimental subject this proves
definitively that the original bacteria
that you found in every case of the
disease is capable of causing that same
disease in an experimental subject and
these are Koch's postulates now there
are a couple of issues with Koch's
postulates first of all with step number
two not every pathogen is able to be
grown in pure culture for example the
bacteria that cause syphilis and leprosy
are very difficult to grow an artificial
media also viruses viruses cause a
number of diseases in humans but because
they are obligate intracellular
parasites they're not able to be grown
in pure culture they have to be grown in
stones so that makes it very difficult
or impossible to fulfill step number two
with viruses and some of those other
types of bacteria also four criteria
three and four you've got this part
right here where you're supposed to show
that the bacterium or the pathogen
causes a disease in a healthy subject
this isn't always ethic home especially
with humans
you can't go take a healthy
Uman inject them with a serious pathogen
and see that they get a disease that's
really not okay but this is why we
usually use animal models for this step
however there are some pathogens that
infect humans but don't readily infect
animals making it difficult to carry out
these steps with those pathogens but
other than that that's how Koch's
postulates work that's how we are able
to prove that a given pathogen causes a
given disease and of course determining
what pathogen causes a certain disease
is the first step in learning how to
treat the disease and how to prevent it
so you can see how it looks postulates
are very very important so that's it for
today I hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching